a new complaint is being filed with the
international criminal court concerning
the death of Al Jazeera journalist
Shireen Abu baklad by Israeli forces the
complaint is on behalf of shireen's
family the palestinian-american
journalist was shot in the head by
Israeli forces while on assignment in
the occupied West Bank in May Shireen
was without azira for 25 years covering
the story of the Israeli occupation
let's go live that of the Hague I'll
just hear a step fasten is there Step
tell us more
well it's now more than four months
after the killing of Shireen Abu akley
and the wounding of her colleague Ali
sumaori and so far there hasn't been any
independent criminal investigation by
Israel let alone someone held
accountable for her killing so what has
now been decided is that the family has
asked lawyers to file a complaint
official Complaint here at the
international criminal court to start an
investigation into her death and also
the injury of Ali sumaori the president
the Palestinian press Syndicate is also
supporting this complaint as is the
independent Federation for journalists
so I'm joined here now by the family
member of Shireen her brother Anton Abu
akley who traveled all the way from
Somalia to be here why are you here why
is this case important good morning it's
very important for us to file this
complaint to the ICC international
criminal court to see Justice for Syrian
which will lead for sure to
accountability for her killing
engineering while covering news so far
the Israeli government has only said
that after an internal investigation
probably an Israeli soldiers shot her
what do you feel about this this is
something we all know it is very clear
that an Israeli soldier shotgun
while covering Israeli encouraging in
Janine and whatever the Israeli report
came up with which was not based on
facts we still believe that the six
reports which came before all clearly
pointed to the Israeli soldier as a
sniper who shot chirin in engineering
Americans have also said it was probably
an Israeli soldier but there was no
evidence that it was intentionally what
do you say to that it is very
intentional like we said before and like
other reports said previously there were
more than 16 17 shots fired at Shireen
towards Syrian and the media and her
colleagues who were standing in that
alley targeting her they even targeted
the person who was trying to pull her
into safety after she was shot down and
they still targeted him shot at him
we know that the Israeli soldiers were
able to identify Syrian she was in full
gear wearing press uh both sides and she
was clearly noted as a press so any
person shooting at a press is
intentionally trying to kill and
assassinate someone in the field doing
their job so it's been four months
you've traveled all over the world to
find Justice now you're here in The
Hague are you getting really frustrated
now
we we have to do this is the least we
can do for shooting we have to pursue
Justice for her in the Hague in the ICC
in other courts whatever we have to do
we will do it to ensure accountability
for Serene for her killing thank you so
much for joining us well the
international criminal court here is one
of their last hopes now to find Justice
Just a year ago in 2021 the court has
decided that it has the jurisdiction to
rule over cases happening in the
Palestinian territories and that's why
the Palestinian government and also
organizations are quite hopeful that
they will eventually be a start of an
investigation here in The Hague
thanks for that step I want to hear his
step thoughts and dad in The Hague